>> Dana: DEMOCRATS FAR LEFT
HEADACHE JUST GOT A LITTLE
WORSE, NOT ONLY DID EVERY MEMBER
OF AOC'S SQUAD EASILY CRUISED TO
VICTORY BUT THE PROGRESS OF
ACTUALLY MORE LAWMAKERS TO THE
ROSTER, AND WITH THE SQUAD'S NEW
POWER, AOC IS SHOWING NO SIGNS
OF BACKING AWAY FROM
CONTROVERSIAL POSITIONS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY HURT DEMOCRATS AT
THE BALLOT BOX, LIKE ANTI-POLICE
RHETORIC.
>> SUBWAY CRIME IS OUT, BUT
LET'S ALSO NOTE THAT SUBWAY
CRIME IS UP AFTER THEY COMMITTED
SO MANY MORE OFFICERS TO THE
SUBWAY SYSTEM, SO THAT ALSO
TELLS US FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE ADDING MORE COPS TO
THE SUBWAY IS NOT SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM, SO THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS I CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Dana: BUT CONTRAST THAT
WITH WHAT NYC'S MAYOR JEFF SAID,
HE THINKS DEMOCRAT ARE THE PARTY
OF LAW AND ORDER.
>> IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE A GOOD CRIME
STORY THEY DIDN'T TELL YOU.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REPUBLICAN
STATES, YOU WILL SEE THE
HOMICIDE RATES ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALLOWED THE
REPUBLICANS TO PIN THE DEFINED
MOVEMENT ON THEM WHEN THAT IS
NOT THE POSITION OF THE MAJORITY
OF DEMOCRATS AND THE
REAL
DEFUNDERS WERE REPUBLICANS.
>> Dana: GREG, THAT IS A LOT
OF SPIN.
>> Greg: IT IS SAD BECAUSE I
ROOT FOR THE GUY BUT IT IS NOT
ABOUT BLAMING THIS CITY VERSUS
BLAMING THE STATES ABOUT SELLING
THE PROBLEM, BOTH ARE RELATED.
IT IS THE CRIME RATES OF THE
CITIES THAT ARE LEADING TO THESE
STATES HAVING, FOR EXAMPLE,
REPUBLICAN-RUN STATE HAS A
RHETORICAL LIBERAL CITIES WITH
HIGH CRIME RATES, THAT IS
WHAT -- WE COULD ARGUE ABOUT
THAT BUT THAT DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING.
THAT DOES NOT LET YOU OFF THE
HOOK.
LOOK, AOC SAYS CRIME WENT UP
ONCE THE POLICE PRESENCE WENT
UP.
THAT IS EITHER THE PRODUCT OF A
DISHONEST MIND, OR A MENTALLY
DISABLED ONE.
BECAUSE THE POLICE ARE A
RESPONSE TO THE CRIME.
OF THE CRIME WAS THEIR FIRST.
HOW CAN YOU LIVE ABOUT THAT?
DOES SHE THINK THE POLICE
ACTUALLY SHOW UP?
THEY PUT UP THE YELLOW CRIME
TAPE, AND THEN THEY GO, "THIS IS
WHERE YOU COMMIT THE CRIME,
EVERYBODY, GET IN HERE."
DO YOU THINK THE CHALK OUTLINES
ARE DRAWN BEFORE THE BODY IS
PLACED IN THERE?
YOU FREAKING MORON.
THIS SHOWS YOU -- BY THE WAY, WE
ARE SO NICE WITH OUR NICKNAMES.
JOE BIDEN BASICALLY DENIGRATES
REPUBLICANS LEFT AND RIGHT WITH
STUPID NAMES, AND WE CALL THEM
"THE SQUAD," I MEAN, HOW FUN IS
THAT?
THERE IS EIGHT MORE IN THE
SQUAD, HOW FUN.
WE SHOULD CALL THEM WHAT THEY
ARE.
THEY ARE STUPID RADICALS.
THEY ARE STUPID, PUNITIVE
RADICALS WHO HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
SOLUTIONS OTHER THAN PUNISHING
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE LIKE MANY.
THEY WIN IN CERTAIN INSTANCES
BECAUSE NOBODY VOTES THERE FOR
ANYBODY -- THERE IS NO
REPUBLICAN PRESENCE.
>> LET'S CALL THEM THE TYRANTS.
>> Greg: LET'S CALL THEM THE
TYRANTS!
>> Jeanine: LEFTISTS.
THEIR LEFTISTS --
>> Greg: THAT IS TOO NICE.
>> Jeanine: OKAY.
WHO'S NEXT?
>> Dana: OKAY.
>> Jeanine: THE WAY THEY ARE
TALKING, WHY ARE WE TAKING ANY
INFORMATION, I HAVE SAID THIS
BEFORE, ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
POLICY OR WHAT IT TAKES TO FIGHT
CRIME.
WHY ARE WE GIVING THEM EVEN A
PEDESTAL OR AN AGENDA?
EVERYTHING THEY ARE DOING IS
DESTROYING THE RIGHTS OF CRIME
VICTIMS IN THIS COUNTRY, AND
PROMOTING CRIMINALS LIKE LETTING
THEM OUT OF JAIL, AND YOU KNOW
WHAT, MR. MAYOR, DID YOU SAY HE
IS A NICE GUY, YOU LIKE HIM?
I DON'T LIKE HIM BECAUSE HE CAME
IN AS A POLICE CAPTAIN --
>> Greg: I SAID I WANTED TO.
>> Jeanine: WELL, I DON'T WANT
TO LIKE HIM BECAUSE HE HAS
PROVED HE CAN'T BE, EVEN AS A
FORMER COP, SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
HOW TO FIGHT CRIME, BECAUSE HE
WILL NOT FIGHT THE POLITICS, THE
POLITICS, THE IDEOLOGY OF THE
LEFT, WHICH IS YOU CANNOT HAVE
CASHLESS FAIL.
AS FOR HER, SHE IS SO STUPID IT
IS STUNNING.
MORE COPS BECAUSE MORE VIOLENCE
ON THE TRAINS AND SUBWAYS.
DID IT EVER OCCUR TO HER THERE
MIGHT BE MORE CRIME, BUT FOR THE
FACT THAT THERE WERE MORE POLICE
THERE?
AND THE WAY SHE THINKS, IT IS
LIKE SO SCREWED UP.
ONE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
OTHER OF YOUR GRADE IS LIKE
SAYING EVERYONE WHO IS A DRUG
ADDICT STARTED WITH MILK.
>> Jesse: THE GATEWAY DRUG.
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS.
>> Jeanine: THE TRUTH IS THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT, AND AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF THAT.
WITHIN HOURS OF CLAIMING CRIME
IS DOWN, SHE GETS ELECTED AND
THERE ARE NOW TEN SQUAD MEMBERS
IN CONGRESS.
>> Dana: JESSE, SHE SAID THIS
IN ANOTHER INTERVIEW WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," SHE SAID
THE OVER RELIANCE AND ON LEANING
INTO REPUBLICAN NARRATIVES ON
CRIME AND SAFETY HURT DEMOCRATS
IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
SO COME ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
KATHY HOCHUL SAID, WHICH IS WHY
ARE YOU SO WORRIED, WHY ARE YOU
HYPERVENTILATING, CRIME IS NOT A
BIG DEAL?
>> Jesse: THEY KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THE NARRATIVE, SHE KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT THE NARRATIVE, WE
HAVE A GOOD STORY TO TELL, SAYS
ADAMS.
WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR STORIES,
DESPITE THE CRIME.
>> Greg: THE ON STATE VERSUS
CITY.
>> WHEN IT IS NOT ABOUT TALKING
POINTS ANYMORE, YOU HAVE TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
SHE ALSO SAYS THIS, I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER SHE THINKS THE COPS
BECAUSE CRIMES ARE THEY DON'T
REDUCE CRIME, I CANNOT FIGURE
THAT OUT.
SHE SAYS, SO THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT CAN SOLVE THE
PROBLEM AND THEN SHE JUST STOPS
TALKING.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANY SOLUTIONS.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR WHAT THEY
ARE BUT SHE DOES NOT HAVE ANY.
>> Dana: THAT IS THE FIRST
TIME SHE HAS TALKED ABOUT SUBWAY
CRIME, ANYWAY.
HOW DO YOU THINK JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO DEAL WITH, OR MAYBE
HAKEEM JEFFRIES, HE IS THE NEW
MINORITY LEADER OF THE HOUSE,
HOW IS HE GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
INCREASE AND EMBOLDENED, VERY
VOCAL SQUAD TYRANT?
>> Greg: TYRANT.
>> Jessica: I THINK
HAKEEM JEFFRIES, WHEN HE BECOMES
SPEAKER, IS GOING TO DO VERY
WELL WITH THE SQUAD.
>> Dana: AGREE WITH THEM?
>> Jessica: NO, HE DOESN'T.
HE IS A MODERATE DEMOCRAT, BUT A
LOT OF TIMES, THERE IS CONFUSION
OVER THE LABEL "PROGRESSIVE."
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS, IT HAS OVER 100 MEMBERS
AND THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN
THERE WHO ARE AS LEFT-WING AS
AOC, OR EVEN RO KHANNA, WHO IS
NOT PART OF THE SQUAD BUT
CERTAINLY VERY LEFT-WING.
UP INTO PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
QUITE MODERATE BELIEFS BUT ARE
PART OF THIS CAUCUS TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE PART OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE GET DONE, RIGHT, AND TO
TALK ABOUT MORE ABOUT
LEFT LEANING ISSUES THAT MATTERO
THEM.
WE WILL SEE HOW ALL OF THAT IS
MANAGED.
BUT THE POINT THAT TALKING ABOUT
CRIME HURT DEMOCRATS IS SO
UTTERLY OFF-BASE, LEE ZELDIN
OBVIOUSLY DID NOT WIN HIS RACE,R
REPUBLICANS ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE, AND WE HAVE NOT FINISHED
THE TALLIES ON ALL OF THIS, BUT
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE A FEW SEATS
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED FROM
THE GOVERNORS RACE DOWN, AND
IGNORING ISSUES THAT PEOPLE FEEL
ALL THE TIME -- THAT DOES NOT
MEAN IT WILL BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE, BUT NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING REAL FEAR IS A
DANGEROUS WAY TO THE POLITICIAN
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING
ON IN L.A. MAYOR'S RACE WITH
RICK CARUSO AND KAREN BASS, THAT
IS BECAUSE OF CRIME AND FEELING
IT IS BEING IGNORED, CRIME AND
HOMELESSNESS, FRANKLY.
>> Jesse: DID THEY GET INVITED
INTO THE SQUAD BY THE SQUAD?
OR DO WE JUST SAY --
>> Jessica: I DID NOT WANT TO
SAY THAT BUT YOU SAID --
>> Jesse: WHO PUT THEM IN THE
SQUAD?
>> Greg: THAT IS WHAT WE DO.
>> Dana: THE TYRANTS.
>> Jesse: THE TYRANTS.
>> Jeanine: BUT THE SQUAD --
>> Greg: FROM SIZED TYRANTS.
>> Jeanine: THE SQUAD PICKED
OR PROMOTED THEM.
>> Jessica: THEY ARE, TOO FAR
LEFT FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
PARTY, BUT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
UP THERE WITH AOC AT EVERY PRESS
CONFERENCE AND RASHIDA TLAIB
AND --
>> Jesse: THAT SHE CALLED
HERSELF "SQUAD," OR DID WE MAKE
THAT NAME UP?
[LAUGHTER]